back here in southern nevada we go to
the coronavirus clark county has now
approved major changes in its plan to
loosen coronavirus restrictions may
first
so now businesses can open with 80
percent capacity
reduced social distancing rules again
that will take effect may 1st it is a
sign of progress
and the urgency to bring back business
hector mejia live at the county building
where the decision has just been made
hector
yeah hey there the planned pass just
minutes ago with clark county
commissioner ted seger bloom being the
only one
voting against it so it all just wrapped
up minutes ago here at the clark county
government center and today we also
learned
the county could do away with all social
distancing and capacity requirements and
as early as a few months from now
and this is the new plan changes were
unveiled today starting may 1st clark
county recommends increasing capacity
from 50 percent to 80 percent that
applies to retail stores
gyms indoor malls community rec centers
also they recommended shrinking social
distancing from six
feet down to three feet capacity and
social distancing requirements in clark
county
will be removed according to the county
when 60 percent of the eligible
population
gets at least one dose of the vaccine
adult entertainment may also
reopen starting may 1st and so can
nightclubs and day clubs
however dancing is still prohibited
until we reach the 60 percent
vaccination benchmark
also today we learn events including
tournaments and other recreational
sporting events with less than 250
attendees
do not need to submit a preparedness and
safety plan
dr fermin lagann with the southern
nevada health district spoke today
backing the updated proposal saying
restrictions
should be loosened primarily on
vaccination rates
yesterday morning he said the first dose
vaccination rate in clark county was
at 44 percent the expectation is to
reach
50 percent before may 1st so what's next
this proposal approved here in clark
county now heads over to the governor
for his consideration and his approval
you can check the updated plan with the
changes highlighted in red on our
website you can just head over to
8newsnow.com
reporting live outside the clark county
government center hector mejia
8 news now actress